Eric in your book the story solution you
claim that you've come up with a
completely new paradigm for writing
screenplays and novels we're curious
what that is hmm
just a quick word on how it came about
first okay because I know it's pretty
outrageous for a lot of people to be
from my to be claiming that you know
what what new Under the Sun can there
possibly be you know from for a long
time for years before I became a
professor here well I was still a
full-time screenwriter I was teaching at
UCLA Extension writers program which is
the largest such writing program in the
world and it's really great really good
people teach there and it was a way to
get out of the house one night a week
out of my room out of my office and I
was working with people who were really
bright and really talented in various
and sundry ways they you know great
characters warm three-dimensional super
dialogue that just kind of crackles and
pops but when they finally turned in
their final project at the end of the
quarter I guess quarter system there and
I read their scripts they just laid
there but they were flat the story
wasn't happening or going anywhere they
would have three or four events and then
try to stretch that out over 110 pages
or how good the whole screenplay would
be and I gave them the books we read the
books we went over it you know the
structure over and over the classic
structure and and and Joseph Campbell
and all of that and yet when they sat
down to write it it just somehow didn't
gel into a concept or command of screen
story structure and screenwriting is
screen story structure more than it is
anything else right so I went looking
for you know as people do for patterns
there had to be a way to teach story
construction
- not to the exclusion of all else but
focus only on finding an objective
objectified way to teach story
construction this is how you build a
house board 1 you know that kind of
stuff and I look though you know
hundreds and hundreds of films and yes I
began to see a pattern that I hadn't
heard anybody talk about before who I
mentioned before or hadn't read about
before and I kind of codified it put it
together as a paradigm and cleaned up
the questions that it raised kind of
stuff and I kept looking
I began more and more convinced and then
I did I set out to prove myself wrong I
mean this I thought was a real important
step so I went back searching through
movies that had been hit movies that you
know emotionally affected audiences all
over the world from pretty far back I
went far back as 1929 Buster Keaton the
general I don't know if you ever saw it
it was one of his last if not his last
silent film it is you know something of
a masterpiece of the silent era same
thing the same beats the same moment the
same sequences accomplishing the same
stuff so I codified it and began to
teach it in in in the grad courses
people were rather cynical about such a
thing to begin with but what I found out
over a few years of working on codifying
it simplifying it you know packaging it
in a way that was understandable and
useful as a tool because that's what it
is it's just a tool and darn good one
useful one - one by one I won them all
over and I proved it yes it's true and
it was like an interesting experience
for all of us
because again it is it is about
discovery now just let me try this okay
for just just a few minutes one of the
single most important aspects of
screenwriting any long form narrative a
novel writing to just screenwriting in
particular is change things thus
everything in the story must keep
changing as it flows it got it has to be
different 5-10 minutes from now than
than it what circumstances were
previously ten minutes ago it has to
keep changing and I I had came to
believe there had to be a pattern of
change and what I discovered was this
this gets a little numeric you know
there is stick with me for this because
it's important and I think enormous ly
useful three acts okay and in a
screenplay you've got three acts first
act in Act one I noticed there are six
sequences following one another that I
called I came to call hero gold
sequences
here's a definition for a hero gold
sequence a hero goal sequence is any two
to seven page section of your screenplay
in which and through which your hero or
heroine pursues one short-term goal
physical short-term goal only one as one
step toward achieving the overall story
goal right just just that little piece
of it and at the end of that seven or so
in nothing is exact you know but seven
or so pages something happened or some
discovery is made by this hero that I
call fresh news in other words they turn
up something that was unknown by them
and
us by the audience about what they are
doing that puts an end to that current
single goal and offers up a new
short-term physical single goal to be
pursued in the next step and that there
are six of these zero goals sequences
six little individual pursuits of
individual specific goals in the
entirety of act 1 and what we call this
many names for this plot point one
there's the the first major turning
point that kind of thing
I call it stunning surprise one when
stunning surprise one happens which ends
act 1 officially and dramatically ends
act 1 and kicks the hero forward
tumbling head-over-heels into Act two
I call it sunny surprise 1 because that
should be I believe the emotional impact
on both the hero and the audience it
needs to be emotional and it needs to be
impactful not abstract that always
happens in here goal sequence 6 always
and it continues in the first half of
the second act there are six more hero
goal sequences and hero goal sequence
number 12 always contains the midpoint
sequence that's a separate discussion
the midpoint is a fascinating part of
movies that work and it's it's it's rich
and layered with things that go on
relative to character growth and
relative to the plot being you know
bumped up to the next level and all but
it always happens in number 12
in the second half of Act two there are
six more wonder of wonders there are six
more hero goal sequences in here will
goal sequence 18 always contains
stunning surprise to not 17
not 1918 in every movie that works for
audiences in other words every hit movie
that you can analyze because it's doing
something right this is the pattern and
then in act 3 it's the only act where it
can vary where the numbers can vary and
in act 3 you have between 2 & 5 hero
goal sequences I don't recommend five
five is good movies have been made with
five like as good as it gets which
happens to be you know one of my
favorite romantic comedies kind of stuff
it has five here are those sequences in
rather extended act three but the
audience is getting antsy and it's time
to get out by then I I the standard the
average of movies that work is 2121 here
of goal sequences 18 for acts one and
two and then another three in Act three
this is a way I know it sounds kind of
weird and mathematical at this point but
this is a way of quantifying change it
tells you in advance this must happen in
these few pages it also goes beyond that
I mean people were asking you well and
what specifically happens in each one of
these can you nail that down in a
general way yeah I do that in the book
you know I said you well these things
usually happen in here real goal
sequence number four you know that kind
of stuff but that's up for grabs and up
for people to play with but structurally
the bones are these 2223 hero goal
sequences laid out in this exact way and
they don't change
you